hi Tom Martin dad I done how long did it
take you to set up the interview with
Vin Scully uh it's a month actually I
got he gave me a couple of windows one
was in spring training he made a brief
visit to Glendale Arizona I really
wanted him in LA obviously at Dodger
Stadium so I pick another date and for
what he told me this would be the only
on camera interview that he was doing
this year you also have video up online
besides the cover story of the
magazine's si.com we had the video of
the interview so it took a while to get
it and I'm glad I didn't add Dodger
Stadium what did you take away what's
two or three things that you took away
that you didn't know or didn't feel
going in well I was really curious to
find out what it is that keeps this guy
going him it's unbelievable that he
could still be at the top of not just
his game but everybody's game after 67
years I don't know anybody who's done
that any job nevermind broadcasting so
there must be something when he gets up
in the morning to have the passion to be
so good at it for so long and never mail
it in and the thing that really struck
me was that he has a tremendous thirst
for knowledge he really wants to find
out new things and that's not just about
baseball but when it comes to baseball
yeah the games that he's doing he still
gets a charge out of finding out
something new and then telling you
during the broadcast as you would call
up a friend or you know instant message
a friend and hey I just heard this or
did you hear about that that thirst for
knowledge to me is really what stands
out for me and it certainly overpowers
whatever if he has any thirst for
attention that he has it's just a the
most humble person you could ever be
around and when you're that great that
really stands out was there any moment
where he thought he was not going to
keep his job or didn't want to keep his
job well there was a moment there when
the Dodgers moved from Brooklyn to Los
Angeles obviously it was a new carrier
carrying the games out in LA on radio
and they wanted their own la voices they
wanted to start anew with Dodger
baseball with new voices and it was
Walter O'Malley the Dodgers owner who
stepped in to know you know Vin Scully
is going to be your now
he's the best that there is and he never
had been himself never had any issues
about going somewhere else but that was
the closest he came to being something
other than the voice of Dodgers so his
sort of philosophy broadcasting
philosophy of how he reaches that that
audience there where he feels like
somebody's sitting next to him even
though somebody is not you know he
doesn't have the color analyst but he
he's saying that he's he feels like he's
trying to talk to somebody next to him
is that correct on that yeah I found
that really interesting then because I
always wondered about that myself did
you have anybody specific in mind or
what was his general approach to talking
to the audience because we all think of
n as our friend right and that's exactly
the way then seated from his side that
he imagines himself sitting basically
next to you on the stand and the way you
would converse to your buddy wouldn't be
about every single you know to one
slider off the black and breaking that
down but things you see or hear in the
course of the day or even non baseball
stuff to bring into a broadcast and I
think that's why people love if I can
use this phrase spending time with Ben
and listening to him and by the way he's
the only one who's talented enough and
he's earned this right but basically to
do the broadcast by himself I know did
he ever have an analyst he did I've gone
back he actually had partnered with
Jerry Doggett for a long time I think
for 32 years okay um but yeah he says
own color guy he's led by play guy he's
actually his own producer and director
as well nobody else does I mean I'm
lucky enough to do broadcast games and
let me tell you there's so much traffic
in the course of a broadcast things you
have to get in sales elements and
certain angles and vendors the white and
you'll hear them sometimes tell the
producer if we can go back and look at
that swing again you will see and he
directs the show as well as the color
commentary and play by play it's just
amazing will never see anything like
that again yeah and I was wondering if
Vin Scully was just coming up now out
what do you get hired and and and if he
did get hired what do you get hired to
be able to go solo in you know the like
we cram as many people in the booth now
as possible then I I think I'm sorry to
say I don't think he would get hired
listen he wouldn't get hired to do the
job the way he does it now those days
are over in fact when he's done this
year that's the end of really the
original form of broadcasting where you
had these well read irritate people come
in to both and you know could carry out
a conversation about anything and
brought eloquence into a broadcast and
didn't shout I mean that's the amazing
thing about then you can go back and my
goodness how many hundreds of great
iconic calls does he have but it's never
about him you know he does have some
energy and excitement he raised his
voice a little bit but he never
overpowers the moment and so itself in
fact a lot of cases so just be quiet and
step back and steps in at the right time
I mean did anybody do that now in terms
of really not having a strong
personality or shouting over call it's
hard to imagine anybody would ever
broadcast the game again the way that
Vin Scully has for 67 years Major League
Baseball network will have been Scully's
called the Dodgers Cardinals game
tonight and tomorrow night we're talking
to Tom Verducci major league baseball
analyst Sports Illustrated senior
baseball writer yeah Bob Costas quoted
in the story when Kirk Gibson hits the
homerun off dennis eckersley then lays
out he doesn't say anything and his bob
says he's letting the crowd sort of a
company Kurt Gibson around the bases and
I thought it was it was brilliant
perception on Bob's part to say that but
also VIN to have the presence of mind in
one of the great moments in baseball
history to not say anything yes and then
when he did come back in he just always
has the perfect works you know the year
the improbable the impossible has
happened and again there's no shouting
there it's eloquence you know it's just
and you can go back whether it's erin
home run at seven-fifteen where he laid
out for about a minute and a half Sandy
Koufax his perfect game in 65 I think
that was about 30 or 40 seconds of
silence on radio after that last out of
the game and by the way go back and even
listen to that last entire half inning I
swear it is poetry the 65 perfect game
of Sandy Koufax having been called that
last inning it really
someone to just make it into a poem and
one of the great American works of art
well you talked about I think Dylan
Thomas and Bob Dylan as a combo platter
therefore for VIN a couple other
questions here for you the Bryce Harper
suspension baseball told us it was for
his actions on the field after the game
so plural means he what you know I
should have been on the field after he
was suspended and that he yells at the
umpire as well and he gets a one-game
suspension what you think of that yeah I
I thought it was proper and i think is
hard of heart sprites knows that listen
I love the guy I love the energy he
brings to the game you know it's the
case where it just bubbled over a little
too far you've nailed it I mean you're
thrown out of a game you can't come back
on the field and tip at you know that's
the violation obviously and many charges
the umpire essentially I mean not
physically but he made fresh made it
obvious that it seemed it just won the
game and his priority was getting to the
curl of the umpire and then he went to
celebration obviously he chose the wrong
words you know directing expletives at
personally the umpire not the actual
call so those things are going to get
you suspended um again I don't think
it's a major deal I don't wanna make a
big deal out of it man it's not a
baseball felony but was the wrong thing
to do and I think the stand up for the
umpires baseball had to at least give
them one game the pitching performances
we've seen with Jake Arrieta Max
Scherzer yeah oh by the way Clayton
Kershaw had another gem last night what
do you would why why is this happening
people are throwing the ball harder and
with more spin than ever before in the
history of the game the rate of
strikeouts has gone up for 11
consecutive years that's not a trend
that's an evolution but also then look
around the game and you try to find me
anybody from age 33 on who is still
getting people out on a regular basis
I'm talking about you know front of the
rotation stuff you don't see it why
because pitchers are throwing so hard
and spinning the ball so hard I just
don't last I mean it's basically is
taking a closer mentality to starting
pitching and I do believe that hitting
is more difficult than it's ever been
for I mean what area Arrieta does with a
baseball throwing so hard with so much
spin and break I mean it's it's both
Scherzer the other nation I mean that
was just ridiculous so I that's what I
think it's pure stuff in an age of
specialization you can train a picture
to do things with the baseball in terms
of velocity much easier than you can a
hitter who's in a reactionary position
so that's why I think we're seeing the
art of pitching at least the power of
pitching get to a level we haven't seen
before what are the rankings the
greatest pitching performance that that
we've had you know factoring in if it's
a Scherzer you know Clemens had 20
strikeouts 10 years apart Kerry Wood
against the houston astros is there one
game whether it's a perfect game or not
the best pitching performance of the
modern era why me just in terms of
importance you know Don Larson in the
World Series you throw a perfect game in
the World Series I'm highly a better
than net but just in terms of domination
I think it's probably Kerry woods game
against the Astros I mean that that was
just crazy no walks 20 punch outs but I
got to tell you Scherzer put himself in
that category now it's hard to say that
because they did scored two runs hit a
couple of balls out of the park but if
you're just talking about your
efficiency I mean dent he faced 33
batters and he only through 23 balls is
just ridiculous you think of 20 punch
outs he probably has 140 pitches and he
doesn't i mean but i would say probably
pure dominance because of the shutout no
walk 20 punch outs Let Go Kerry Wood
yeah I'm right there with you and having
you know that was his fifth major league
start yeah that was crazy I mean it with
a lineup loaded with right-handed
hitters but that I'm whatever you want
to call it slider slur people thing it
was risby if this is a frisbee from
outer space uh not but that's part of
the problem to some of these guys you
throw like that like a Jose Fernandez
and Matt Harvey when they're so good so
young it's really hard to sustain it for
a long career and that was the case with
carries it was so violent that breaking
ball you almost knew you were looking at
a short career hey congrats on the cover
story there Tom good to talk to you and
safe travels
my pleasure dan thank you always a
pleasure to be on tonight's Tom Verducci
Sports Illustrated senior baseball
writer the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience